Warning, this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children. Viewer discretion is advised.
What's the song we love so much of
Olivia's? That was "Get Him Back." "Get
Him Back."
He wants to get him back for you. Aw,
thanks, Billy. And then what do you want
to do when you get him back?
Punch him in the penis.
Oh my goodness.
Am I a bad influence on your children?
No, no, no, no. She's always been this
way. DON'T WORRY.
YEAH, just it's just another way of
expressing it.
Absolutely. Billy, do you want to play
your favorite? Mhm. Okay. Wait. All
right, Billy. Here comes Billy's
favorite. All right.
Punch him in the penis.
Guys, I think I'm done here.
What in the world did I just watch? It
is not easy to shock me at this point,
and I'm shocked. Yeah, I was shocked
when I saw this. I was like, "Are you
kidding me?"
What's up, guys? Welcome back to LED
Live, where we expose the darkness with
the light of Christ, and boy, do we have
a show for you today. In this show,
we're going to talk about teenage idols,
the music that teenagers tend to listen
to. So, we are discussing Ariana Grande,
Sabrina Carpenter, Harry Styles, Olivia
Rodrigo, and Billie Eilish. I haven't
heard of
some of those. At least three of them.
Yeah. So, Billie Eilish, you guys are
familiar with her picture here on the
right. I put them all on there to show
you guys what's coming up. Wow. And uh
Harry Styles has an interesting t-shirt
he's wearing. We're going to discuss
that, too.
And Ariana Grande, what's up with the
triangles? Yeah,
I like the position of the triangle.
Exactly.
So, Billie Eilish, it is idol teen idol
number one, everyone. Ding, ding, ding,
ding. Let's look at what she is up to.
So,
Billie Eilish
has
uh two songs on the same album
that are very interesting. Do you guys
remember the song from Billie Eilish
where she says, "All the good girls go
to hell"?
Yep. Remember that song?
What happened in the song? We're about
to look at it, but what what happens in
the music video?
I think she falls from heaven, like
Lucifer fell from heaven, slapped into
some nasty tar tar or something like
that, and like is like walking down the
street, but she says, "To me, the most
iconic line of there was like, 'My
Lucifer is lonely.'"
Exactly. So,
it's interesting
climate change. Don't you remember?
Okay, you guys are looking way too deep
into it.
So, on that same album, there is another
song called "bury a friend." I was
showing Mikey this yesterday. There is a
particular clip in this song that you'll
probably recognize because the exact
same clip is used for "all the good
girls go to hell." But first, let's look
at the lyrics.
For the debt I owe, got to sell my soul
cuz I can't say no, no, I can't say no.
Then my limbs all froze and my eyes
won't close, and I can't say no, I can't
say no.
She's clearly saying
said, "Got to sell my soul." She's
clearly saying, "Got to sell my soul, I
got a good debt to pay," right?
Now, let's look at this clip that I was
talking about that's from her music
video "bury a friend." Let's see if you
guys recognize
this particular clip from
also the music video for "all the good
girls go to hell."
Wow.
like, wait, she she she dies and then is
like now she's proceeding forward or
She in this whole music video, she's
basically walking through hallways.
She's literally singing, "I want to end
me" over and over and over, which again
should be disturbing if teenagers are
singing, "I want to go kill myself."
That's what I thought I heard, yeah.
And why? Why why why why why are they
doing this? But the people when we
talked about that, like you mentioned it
that some of her lyrics kind of promote
suicide and all that, and then people
are like, "No, she understands me. She
helped me not commit suicide." Yeah, I
do not understand like why, you know,
you would want to be around something
like this. I mean, clearly but the Bible
and Christianity talks about, you know,
to to focus on positive and good things,
right?
What's the other things that lovely and
Yeah, Philippians 4:8. Those those
things are going to help our minds
increase into better space, right? If
you're just sitting there going like
death, kill, drugs, rap, demonic. I
mean, did you notice how like demonic
that looked?
Like almost like you you are you are
being oppressed by these people that you
cannot see in the shadows.
Exactly. And and that's what this whole
music clip seems to be about. She's
walking through a hallway, and they just
grab her and stick a bunch of syringes
in her. Inject her with a black liquid.
Exactly. And if you pause it, you see it
flashing between her flesh and like
these veins that are popping up, black
veins. So, it's clearly they're trying
to transform her into something else by
force, Mhm. which you see in all good
all the good girls go to hell,
transforms her into Lucifer.
Exactly. So, that's where we're going
next. So, these are the lyrics for "all
the good girls go to hell." "My Lucifer
is lonely, standing there killing time,
can't commit to anything but a crime." I
find this interesting. She keeps
referring to Peter over and over, which
we know is a character from the Bible.
"Peter's on vacation, an open
invitation, animals, evidence, pearly
gates, reference to heaven, look more
like a picket fence once you get inside
them. Got friends, but can't invite
them." So, I have one thing. When she
mentions Peter, and then she men-
mentions the gates of heaven,
Peter's supposed to be in some peo-
people's minds like the gatekeeper of
heaven. So, if he's on vacation, it's
like, "I'm not going to heaven anyway."
That makes sense. It also says that they
hell will not prevail against the end.
So, by saying Peter's asleep or he's on
vacation, he's not even around. Hell's
coming for you. Right. Interesting.
What does she mean by the pearly gates
are like a picket fence? Instead of like
something that's keeping you out, like a
jail. Or marvelous-looking, it's just a
joke. Yeah, exactly. That's what I was
thinking, too. Yeah. So, then it
continues. It says, this is toward
toward the end of the song, "My Lucifer
is lonely, there's nothing left to save
now. My God is going to owe me, there's
nothing left to save now."
So, who your God owes you something, or
is it like Satan who's your God and owes
you something? I don't know.
But
very interesting stuff. Uh definitely it
seems like uh um putting Lucifer on a
pedestal, and even more so in the music
video. Let's take a look.
My Lucifer is lonely.
So, this is pretty intense. And again,
there is a progression where she has a
music video clip where she says, "Sold
my soul, blah blah blah blah." The
syringes go in her back, and this video
starts with the syringes in her back,
and she comes down from heaven, and now
is a devil herself, and says, "Oh, my
Lucifer is lonely." Yeah, and all the
good girls go to hell, you know, there's
such an attack on
Christians being good, perfection, all
that.
The media, it's just like there's no
originality to it. It's always a
constant attack on God, Christians, his
government. And I I just looked up
what's the
main demographic that's listening to
Billie Eilish because people think, "Oh,
you know, okay, well, it doesn't matter.
I'm an adult." Um
the majority are females, like double
it. Girl more girls are doubling boys,
but uh
there's 20 22% of females that are 13 to
17 that are listening to Billie Eilish.
The the main majority is 18 to 24
females. I mean, that's just like 40%.
But that's a young I mean, these are
young people that are listening. 18 to
24, so 13 to 24 are who are listening.
When it gets to 25 and 34, it's like it
plummets.
So, young people are listening.
Because she's only like 21, 22 right
now, so
I I know so many young kids that that
like her music. Yep. She's a talented
singer. I think that that in in itself
is feeding this, and then they're
accepting whatever
she's slime she's doing, yeah.
The message, yeah. Yep.
So, let's go back to "bury a friend."
Now, she did a live performance
uh on Jimmy Kimmel, and remember that
she was talking in this song about
selling her soul, right? Let's look at
this performance and at the end of the
performance, what happens?
See, here's another thing, too,
I want to point out about this. You
heard her voice right there in the tail
end.
But it's highly produced before that
point.
I really think these demons are are
singing through these people.
Oh, absolutely they are.
And I like when you actually hear their
real voice, it's like da da da da that
good. Well, yeah, so Beyoncé said, she's
like, "I you know, when I'm on stage, I
can sing loud, I can sing strong, but
that's not me."
It was way better than than I expected
and
Sasha was in full effect.
Sasha is my alter ego.
And when people see me,
sometimes I think that
when they meet me and they speak with
me,
they're expecting Sasha.
And um
I'm really kind of shy and not really
shy, but more reserved and um
nothing like Sasha.
But
I guess I wouldn't be very entertaining
on the stage, so Sasha comes out. And
she's fearless.
You know, she can she can do things that
I cannot do when I'm in rehearsal. I
mean, I can try, but then it just
doesn't happen. I can sing notes and
sing strong and do all these things that
when I'm just by myself, I can't do. And
I remember right before I performed,
I raised my hands up
and it was kind of the first time I I
felt something else
come into me and I knew
that was going to be my coming out
night. Nicki Minaj is Roman, like they
will tell you that's not me up there.
Yeah. And like yeah, so she's I mean,
it's like, "I want it in me. It's all
It's happy. Let's kill ourselves,
everybody." You know, it's like that's
how Satan is brainwashing people. Let's
make it Let's disguise it. Let's put it
in this package like Disney package
like, "I want it in me. Yay." And And
what's crazy, too, is it's like she's
got this crazy huge fan base right there
like, "We love you. We love everything
that you say to us, right?" If people
would actually take a step back and be
like, "This is damaging."
Why would you be wanting to support
this? I mean, what if nobody listened to
this kind of stuff?
Why would I listen to that and turn that
off, right? This this This is disturbing
to me that people are gravitating
towards this. Yeah. So, did you guys see
what what came up on the sheet? A hand,
kind of like a
Well, it's demonic looking hand.
Yeah. Yep, exactly. So, she literally
was just like bent back in front of that
thing. Which, by the way, in dancing,
that takes a lot of effort. You actually
almost have to open yourself up to the
chakras to even fold like that.
What do you mean by that? What do I mean
by that? Oh my goodness, that takes so
much
Cuz you are a hip-hop dancer for those
who don't know.
Yes. And so, when
I guess I used to get up on stage and it
would kind of just overtake me. I didn't
have to worry about prepping. It would
just happen. The music.
But for her to do that, she's either
letting it just enter her
to happen that way or she's prepped for
that, which takes a lot of
physical stretching and strength, but
also like meditating usually. Yeah. So,
that's all I mean. I can just like bend
over and just hang there for a while and
make it look super lax. Like it takes a
ton of core strength.
I'm not saying that someone can't be
able to do that in a normal fashion, but
that just didn't look natural. Natural,
that's right. And I think we should give
you some credit because you were in the
hip-hop industry. You were doing this
professionally. Yeah. You know, so it's
not like you're just saying something
out of thin air. Like you actually know
what you're talking about. And you
experienced music just kind of taking
over and you and and you
feeling the music and doing things that
you normally couldn't do, right?
Yeah. So, what's the imagery of this
whole thing that there's a devil behind
the curtain? Yes.
How come people don't see it for what it
is? Right. I'm sure people People are
saying, "Well, she's just singing about
when you go to sleep, where do you go?"
But like putting all the pieces
together, like why is she talking about
suicide? Why is she talking about
selling my soul? And then there's just
this demonic being when the same imagery
shows up in her music video, right? And
I don't I'm not trying to knock her
talent or anything. You're talking about
she's a good singer.
There is a a catchiness to it, but in in
all honesty, I'm not saying she can't
sing, but what I'm hearing
isn't like an amazing voice like you
like on the voice where they turn
around, they push the button like, "Wow,
what is this voice?" It's all just like
depressing and it's not about that. And
that's what people like this is like
when I grew up, it was Nirvana. It was
like, "Nothing in the way." You know, it
was real depressing.
Yeah, so it's like they're
I think this is what the mainstream is
pushing. We want society to be
depressed. We want society on
pharmaceutical drugs and anti-suicide
and anti-depressant and all these
things.
Because that's what Satan wants. He
wants to intoxicate everybody's minds so
that he can
be their god.
Right, that's an interesting point. I
think that's why people are gravitating
to this because A, they're dark, they're
demonic, they're depressed, and they are
doing drugs.
So, let's move on to another another
song on the same album where it's called
You Should See Me in a Crown. These are
the lyrics.
Bite my tongue, bite my tongue. Wearing
a warning sign, wait till the world is
mine. Visions I vandalize. Cold in my
kingdom size. Fell for these ocean eyes.
You should see me in a crown. I'm going
to run this nothing town. Watch me make
them bow one by one, one by one. Now,
she
uh has a music video out, right? What's
the symbol on her crown? Yeah, crosses
on there.
Christian crosses. So, look at these
pictures here. She performed this song
live on the Ellen Show. Again, crosses
everywhere. Necklaces and uh earrings.
She's wearing snake uh rings. Um I just
find this really interesting because
again, it seems like in her music on
this album, everything kind of works
together, right? In the other song two
songs, they work together. She's telling
a story, a progressive story.
This made me think and I don't want to
make conclusive statements here because
I I want to be careful with that.
However,
we know about Roger Morneau's story,
right? For those who haven't heard at
home, we'll put a link a title card here
at the top. You can watch it for
yourself. He was a Satanist who got
involved with like the Satanic secret
societies, came out of that and the
demons came after him and just like
attacked him left and right. He did an
interview years ago before he died. He's
a He's a
Canadian man from Montreal.
And in it he said,
the reason why people worship Satan,
especially higher up, right? Is because
they genuinely believe that Satan's
going to eventually rule the world, have
the world to be his kingdom, which was
unrightfully taken from him by God, and
he's going to defeat Jesus and everybody
who worships him gets to live with the
idea of do what thou wilt. Shall be the
whole of the law forever, right? He said
you guys have got a great future ahead
of you.
Because we've been told
the high priest of our society, secret
society, has been told that the master
has very special plans for you, too.
Now, what did he mean by the master?
Uh Satan.
And
we were interested to hear more about
it.
And he told us he says, "Look,
we worship spirits.
We worship Lucifer the Lucifer and all
his angels. They're just as beautiful as
they did they were before they were cast
out of heaven.
He says, "That was a misunderstanding in
the whole thing." He says, "The mighty
inhabitants of the galaxies."
And he says, "Our master was
misunderstood and God did not bear with
him like he does with with people that
make mistakes today.
So, we're in a warfare, good against
evil.
And we happen to be the evil ones, but
we're not that bad. He says, "I look at
this business between the force of good
and evil." He says, "You believe in in
One person believe in God, the other one
believe in Lucifer.
It's like politics."
So, the great controversy
is real. And you've heard someone talk
about it that's on the other side.
And to these people,
they are sold to the fact that Christ
will not return to this planet with
power and great glory.
He's going to abdicate all claims to the
planet because this
the high priest once said
that uh
Christ will abdicate all claim to the
planet because he knows that it is
lawfully and rightfully Satan's.
And at And at that time he says,
Lucifer
You mentioned Lucifer a lot of times,
but he mentioned Satan also. He says,
"The master" usually they they like to
talk about the master. The master will
resurrect his people from the graves.
And then, so we see her selling her soul
in this album. She says it. Then she
honors Lucifer in the next song with the
clips being very similar. And then on
the same album, she talks about, you
know, um I'm going to rule this town.
I'm going to have my kingdom. I'm just
waiting my time. The world is mine.
They're all going to bow for me. So, to
me, that's just really an interesting
concept. I'm not making conclusive
statements. I'm just saying it's really
interesting. And then on top of that,
she's wearing a crown with the Christian
crosses. And during her show, the
Christian crosses are everywhere, but
also the snake, which is a
representative of Satan. You think about
what that statement means, I'm going to
make them bow. Mhm.
forced Mhm. worship. That's what the
devil is aiming towards. So, even though
this in a weird way is not overtly like
pushing towards religion, it's setting
people up for what's going to happen in
the end. Mhm. There is going to be a
religious order that says, "Worship or
die." And look at what this is kind of
even preparing those that aren't setting
foot in church. Many of these people
probably aren't, but they're getting
that message. Yeah. And God never uses
force when it comes to worship of him.
It says every knee shall bow because
when they see him,
you know it's he's the truth. Like he is
God. Your only response is to do that.
Yeah, you can't you have no choice. It's
not forced, but this is just reality.
It's the truth. Now, to say I'll make
them bow, I think I've heard I've seen
it in so many different songs, and I
want to put together something about
this
that I really think that Satan is
These are his hymnals. His praises are
going out to the world
through music like this, through these
people that say, "I sold my soul."
They're openly saying I sold my soul. To
who? To Satan. And now he's giving her
lyrics to write about the world is mine.
I'm going to make everyone bow. This is
his song. And everybody's chanting along
and raising their hands and filling
stadiums. Yeah. That's what Satan wants.
He wants the world to worship him, and
it's happening in all these concerts.
And I like what you're saying there
because I think a lot of people will
say, "No, but this is not Satan. Like
this is or or like this is just a music
industry doing this thing." But what I
find interesting is that she was on
Jimmy Fallon, and she actually says,
admits, she says, "I direct direct all
my music videos. Why? Because I want to
know exactly what I'm putting in there."
So, she's directing the videos.
them. And she says, "I do this. Watch
this." And you direct your own videos,
or have done it this which is extra
pressure. What Why? Why put that on you?
Why put that more pressure on yourself?
It's it's a lot of work. So, you know,
sometimes I wish that I didn't want to
do it so bad. I just really want to do
it. Like I just there's not
I don't know. I feel like when you have
your own idea and you know what you
want, sometimes it's just the best way
to go about it is to just do it
yourself, even though it takes much more
out of you. Is it really her idea?
That's the question.
idea? Maybe she was forced to say this.
Or maybe maybe she was influenced by a
spirit. Exactly.
speaking to her and through her, then
she's going to get exactly what needs to
go into that music video. Yep. You know,
I just had a dream. I woke up and I I
dreamed that I was getting needles stuck
in my back, and I was Lucifer, and I
felt Who knows?
Yeah.
So, anyway,
just wanted to put it out there like
this is her making these decisions. Now,
Billie Eilish came into the news
recently because she did an article with
the Rolling Stone that people are pretty
shocked about with by what she said. So,
let's take a look. This is the comment
section with Brett Cooper from the Daily
Wire commenting on this. Okay, so for
some context, if you didn't know, Billie
Eilish came out as lesbian like last
year. She is ready to talk about it big
time, and she did in a new Rolling Stone
profile. And the article is titled,
"Billie Eilish would like to reintroduce
herself." The only thing that stands out
to people, the only thing that people
are talking about is her sexuality
because she said the most outlandish
things that 10 years ago would have
stayed private. Like it would be
ridiculous. You would be ostracized if
you said things like this. And now,
sadly, it's just commonplace. And fair
warning, what we're about to talk about
is very sexual. Billie Eilish tells
Rolling Stone about her song Lunch and
realizing her sexuality. Quote, "I wrote
some of it before even doing anything
with a girl, and then wrote the rest
after it. I've been in love with girls
for my whole life, but I just didn't
understand. Until last year, I realized
that I wanted my face in a
I just don't even know. I don't even
know how to respond to that. I'm just
like we could have done without you
saying that. I wish that would have been
a secret, but you've mentioned it. Just
thank you. Let's move on and never speak
about this again. Like we do not need to
know what happens on your mattress. So,
then PopCrave posted another quote from
the article. Billie Eilish tells Rolling
Stone that she likes to masturbate
in front of a mirror. Mhm. I heard that.
I wish I didn't hear that, but I just
heard that.
And again, I am just so sorry. I'm just
going to rush through this. Quote,
"Partly because it's hot, but it also
makes me have such a raw, deep
connection to myself and my body, and
have a love for my body that I have not
ever really had. I've got to say looking
yourself in the mirror and thinking I
look really good right now is so
helpful. I have learned that looking at
myself and watching myself feel pleasure
has been an extreme help in loving
myself, and accepting myself, and
feeling empowered and comfortable. I
promise there are other ways to love
yourself. I promise there are other ways
to feel comfortable in your own skin,
and it starts with not publishing this
in Rolling Stone. Quote, "People should
be it, man. I can't stress it enough. As
somebody with extreme body issues and
dysmorphia that I've had MY ENTIRE
LIFE."
LIKE NO WONDER THAT IS THE ONLY thing
people are talking about from the
article. What else is there to talk
about? That is like absurd. Yeah. Wow.
I just thought of Amigomara, man. I
would agree. And And the one thing, I
mean, I don't want to hang on this idea
too long either, but the idea about
masturbating to yourself, I mean, we
talked about this on this channel many
times, right?
God gave sexual pleasure to bring a man
and a woman close together and knit them
together in a marriage context, right?
So, that when the ultimate thing you
could possibly do for somebody is to
give them pleasure, right? So, now
you're talking about somebody who is
narcissistically staring at themself in
the mirror and getting off on that. Mhm.
This is where our world is at. And this
is what's being taught to teens.
Some teenager is reading that and is
like 14, 15, 16, and she's like,
"I've never tried that before." Right. I
like her. I like her music. I like her
music, and they're in their puberty,
right? And they're like ready to explore
and asking questions about sex, and this
comes up, and they're like, "My parents
aren't home. Maybe I should try that,
too." Mhm. You know what I mean?
there is something to this, though. In
the witchcraft world, this is how you
become a god to yourself. Really?
Instead of acting This is going to be in
the androgyny video. But it's a ceremony
that the Wiccans do to actually
get rid of all genders and become
genderless
in the Wiccan world, and you become like
God by doing that. Wow.
either do it in a sexual act with others
or by masturbating by yourself. Oh,
interesting.
And getting that pleasure from yourself.
Because then you ultimately don't need
anyone. Yeah. It's referred to as
self-abuse. Mhm. Like a lot of a lot of
times it's talked about as self-abuse,
right? I thought thought about that. Why
do they call it self-abuse? What what's
actually happening? Like are you
actually like harming yourself, right? I
think you are. I think you are. You're
harming that connection and that peace
that that God intended for you to to
glue your marriage together because
marriage is tough, right?
Mhm. Well,
marriage is not easy. Look, science
keeps proving the Bible. Yes. said to
look at a woman to lust after her is the
same as committing adultery in your
heart. Now, they
with MRI machines and stuff, they're
showing your brain fires off. There's
medical science out there that says that
pornography causes brain damage. Yep.
Right. Yep. And I don't think it's just
watching something on screen. It's the
act that happens while you're watching
it, right?
Right. Right. It's harming the system
that God set in place. And when God
creates a system, especially the God of
pleasure, he has said in his Bible that
no eye has seen, no ear has heard
anything that he has in store for those
that love him, right? The pleasures that
he's he's got on the other side of this
crazy mess that we're in right now is
un- we can't even think about what's
over there, right? All we can think
about is this this momentary pleasure
that we get here on this Earth. And
dude, this is breaking that system.
Young kids, I hope that you're
listening. If any young kids are
listening to this, please don't break
the model that God gave you. You will
not be sorry if you just do life like
God wanted us to do it.
Yeah. Wait for marriage is the best
decision you could ever make. And but
like you said, the the momentary
pleasure that
I we did something about um
the Disney's road to destruction or
whatever, path to destruction, and how
many people started out Christian and
left Christianity just for the sake of I
want to have sex this type of way,
either out of wedlock or LGBT or I'm
pansexual or whatever. How many people
are missing eternity, choosing to miss
out on eternal life for momentary
pleasure on Earth? Mhm. Yeah. Crazy,
man. Yeah. Definitely.
So,
speaking of that topic, speaking of her
song Lunch that
Brett Cooper is talking about,
uh Coachella happened recently. Major
festival. Where is it? California or
something, I think.
Yeah, it's in uh near Palm Springs, and
And so, Billie Eilish was performing and
played song lunch. This is uh the song
lunch.
Oh man.
Wow, interesting, huh? There's such a
push to make this
so trendy and popular and like everyone
should be gay. And she's totally
cross-dressing. She looks like a dude.
Yeah, she's so masculine and this is not
attractive. No.
She is an attractive girl.
Once again, attacking sexuality is one
of the two things God instituted, the
marriage and he instituted the Sabbath
in the Garden of Eden. And the marriage
is really, once again, something that
God said, "Do it this way."
Here's the parameters of that. Here's
the fences of that.
way for you.
Here's the fences of that. And and and
you think about what God did with
putting a tree in the middle of the
garden. He showed us, "Here's life.
Here's some fences. That's off off off
um bounds, right?" And and what this is
pushing is the bounds of everything and
it's really an attack on God. It's
really telling God, "You know what? You
told me I can't do this, but I'm going
to do it in your face and I'm going to
make a bunch of other people do it,
too." It's the spirit of lawlessness.
That's what's coming. The Antichrist
spirit is the spirit of lawlessness.
There's no laws on gender, there's no
laws of physics or nature or biology or
sexuality. It's a free-for-all. It's
fluid. Everything just goes. Mhm, yep.
Yep.
So,
Billie Eilish, that's that segment.
We are off to teenage idol number two.
Anybody heard of her?
I would have thought that was Megan Fox
in the picture.
So, I didn't hear of her, either,
because like we don't really listen to
this stuff. Um This is AI? No, this is
her.
Um and so, apparently, she was on
Disney, as well, just like our final
contestant for today, Sabrina Carpenter.
And um so, she was Yeah, Disney star,
young girl, 21, 22-ish.
And broke out as a musician and uh
teenagers love her. So, let's take a
look what she's all about.
So, this is a uh little news clip from
The Hollywood Reporter, where it talks
about how she is handing out
contraceptives at her concerts for the
other teenage girls that might want to
sleep around.
And also, this was done by an abortion
clinic. So, or like an an abortion
uh what do you call organization? So,
we'll see We'll see what the message is.
Olivia Rodrigo's team is reportedly no
longer allowing abortion funds to hand
out contraceptives on her GUTS world
tour.
This news comes following morning-after
pills and condoms being given out at
Rodrigo's show in St. Louis by the
Missouri Abortion Fund. According to
reports that surfaced on Friday,
Rodrigo's team told the abortion funds
that she's partnered with for future
tour stops that they're no longer
allowed to hand out contraceptives. DC
Abortion Fund Communications Manager
Jade Hurley said in a statement to The
Hollywood Reporter, "The GUTS world tour
is asking funds not to bring emergency
contraception, condoms, or lube to tour
stops. We hope to see this change before
DC's date on July 20th." While the
singer's St. Louis show went viral, it's
worth noting the abortion funds tabling
at previous shows, like the Carolina
Abortion Fund at the March 8th concert
in Charlotte, North Carolina, also had
contraceptives available. Ahead of
kicking off her GUTS world tour, Rodrigo
announced she was launching a new
initiative, The Fund for Good, through
which she would partner with local
chapters of the National Network of
Abortion Funds. So, she wanted to
collaborate with these abortion funds
and I guess her tour organization's
staff eventually said, "No, not
anymore." I don't know why,
but she invited them and they were there
for at least one concert. And yeah,
handing out condoms to what? Teenagers?
Uh What are they saying that she's not
allowed to anymore? Is that what they're
saying? The Yeah, I guess I guess the
organizations were not allowed to come
anymore, but they were there to her
invitation. Wow. And this is like uh her
I was trying to look up her target
audience. It says like 15 and up. I mean
How old is she? She's like 21, 22. See,
here's Here's also part of the problem,
too. It's like you're 21, 22 and it's
like you may be engaging in this kind of
behavior, but
Don't lead other people
15-year-old like I've got a 14-year-old
right now and I'd be mortified if there
was a place encouraging this.
No, this is 16 to 22 is like the target
audience for her.
Yeah. Wow, dude. Wow.
So,
besides this, And what's crazy is how
normalized it's become to dress like a
prostitute on stage.
I mean, is she like literally wearing
like fishnets and a and a some kind of
lingerie? And now, what comes on
national television, slapped on a
magazine at the grocery store, your
daughter buys the CD and she's dressed
literally like a prostitute on the side
of the road. Another thing I noticed
about that clip that you just played
was, do you remember in Taylor Swift,
the video we did on her,
she was floating over the crowd? Yeah,
she's floating over the crowd. I saw
something with I think it was maybe
Nicki Minaj in like a Ferrari or
something like this that was like
floating over the crowd. What does that
do when people are elevated up there
like that? That's your star that you're
there to like worship. Yep, you're
bowing down to her.
You're looking up to this being coming
up. When you come to these type of
environments, this is a Babylonian
worship ceremony. Yeah, definitely.
That's what it is.
So, what is part of a Babylonian
ceremony as well is obviously sex,
again. So,
this is her song bad idea, right?
Now, this song is about her wanting to
get back together with her ex and, you
know, like going over to his house and
constantly it comes up of like it's a
bad idea. Everybody in the video,
everybody's saying, "No, it's a bad
idea. Don't do it. Don't get back
together. Don't do it." But then she's
like, "Eff it." And then she goes over
to his house and this is the scene where
she lays on his bed with fireworks. What
do you guys think this is supposed to
represent? Right. You know, like when do
you have a bed and fireworks? Fireworks
on the man, though.
Yeah.
I remember when I played The Sims
heavily, I was addicted. Every time they
had the woohoo, which was sex,
fireworks, right?
Anyway,
wanted to point this out like this This
is what's being portrayed to teenagers
like, "Get your free condom, have sex
with your boyfriend out of wedlock. Oh,
and if then if you get pregnant, you
just go and abort your child because uh
she'll give you an opportunity to do
so."
you know, even if everybody says it's a
bad idea, you know, do it anyway.
So, like if your parents are telling you
don't do it, do it anyway. It's nothing
like sex So, so the thing is like when
your teenage kid, especially daughters,
hears this song,
right? And you sit her down, Scotty, you
have a teenager. You sit sit her down
and you're like, "Hey, look, this is why
we don't have sex for marriage, right?
It's the Bible, this is the logic behind
it." And she if if, because you don't
let her listen to this stuff, but if she
were to hear this song over and over and
over and it's her idol, she's going to
look up more to her than to you.
What is she going to think? "No, I'm
going to do it. Eff it, you know?"
Because let's be real, as a parent, how
many times are you actually sitting down
and having that conversation? Yeah, not
often. That awkward conversation maybe
comes up a couple times, right? I mean,
seems like in in
Yeah, in this world, I I have actually
had to mention it multiple times to my
kids, but not in the frequency
that people have their their CD player
on repeat or whatever, you know,
playlist they
So, we saw this in the beginning. She is
Olivia.
And so, Olivia Rodrigo. And so, they
pick her up and uh let's see their
reaction.
Oh, there's a hitchhiker up here.
Should we pick her up? Wait a minute. I
think we should pick her up, for sure.
What What is it?
Hey!
Do you guys mind if I hitch a ride?
Could I come with you?
Hi there. How are you?
Hi!
That's
That's Billie. What's your name? I'm
Olivia. Do you guys mind if I hitch a
ride to school with you guys? Well, you
have to buckle up, Olivia, if you want
to ride with us safely.
that. Deal. Jane, what do you think?
Hi, Jane.
I'm Olivia.
Nice to meet you.
You look so cute today.
Billie, what do you think about this?
What's the song we love so much of
Olivia's? Get him back
for you. Get him back for
He wants to get him back for you. Oh,
thanks, Billie. And then what do you
want to do when you get him back?
Punch him in the penis.
Oh my goodness.
My a bad influence on YOUR CHILDREN?
NO, NO, NO, NO. He's always been this
WAY. DON'T WORRY.
YEAH, it's just it's just another way of
expressing it.
Absolutely.
Do you want to play your favorite?
Okay. All right. Here comes Billy's
favorite. All right.
Punch him IN THE PENIS.
THAT GIRL IS 11 TOPS. She's She knew who
this woman was in plain clothes. She's
singing the song.
Dude, what?
Guys, I think I'm done here.
What in the world did I just watch? And
this is like broadcast on mainstream
television to make you think it's normal
for an 11-year-old girl to sing these
songs.
when he says he wants to punch him in
the penis.
Brainwashed with the laugh track. It is
not easy to shock me at this point, and
I'm shocked. Yeah, I was shocked when I
saw this. I was like, are you kidding
me? How old is that boy? Like five, six?
But it's because we don't watch this
stuff on daily basis. We're more
sensitized.
People over the years have been seeing
the same stuff over and over to where
they're not shocked at this. They're
like, "Oh, isn't that cute?" Well, she
even knows it. She goes, "Oh, I'm so
sorry. I've had such a bad effect on
your children."
parents laugh it off.
Yeah.
Okay, fine. Listen, yeah, I want to
punch him in the penis. She said it
twice.
Yeah. And they like, "Should we play the
song where you that makes you want to
punch them in the penis? Let's do it."
You know, like
Wow. I don't want to see the thumbnail
for this show. This is crazy, bro. And
if anyone says, "No, but Bebe Rexha
doesn't affect my kids." Um,
I'm just saying. I'm just say
I think we said enough about this.
But
I hope everybody at home is as shocked
as we are. I really hope so. Yeah, is
this girl going to go to a concert where
she's passing out condoms and lube? I
mean There's a reason why we talk about
these things. And I And I mean this with
all honesty of my heart. I know a lot of
people that watch our show,
they may never ever have their kids
listen to or pay attention to this.
But you also need to as a parent
understand
what's out there.
Because if you don't understand what's
out there, it's real easy. Like I don't
I've never even heard of this person. I
mean, if my kids came home and said,
"Hey, I got this new artist that I'm
listening to or whatever like this." I
would have no context unless I actually
went and looked it up. So, here's a call
to parents, right? If your kids start to
listen to music, no matter who they are,
even if they're Christian artists, look
them up. Do some research, parents,
please. Because this is what's trying to
be fed to your kid. And you have like
this sense of security like, "Oh, it's
on the radio, you know, it's FCC
approved or whatever." Like there used
to be a time when there was censorship
and all that. And so you think, "Well,
if it's on the radio, it must be okay."
And it sounds poppy and fun. And what
are they singing about? And are they
passing out condoms and lube at the
concert? Wow.
You guys ready for a contest? I don't
know if I want to continue forward.
Tap out. Are these getting worse?
Do it for our audience, Scotty Who.
I would say this is the top. Well,
actually I don't know. Wow. You guys
want to look at Harry Styles'
interesting T-shirt we saw in the
beginning. Oh my goodness. This guy This
guy is a is a piece of work.
Oh my goodness. This is safe sex. Safe
sex, and what are they doing?
You've got to be kidding me.
So, let's look at this T-shirt. This is
from Keith Haring. Do you guys know who
Keith Haring is? No. He did a lot of
'80s graphics like this.
Yeah, he's an artist, and he's a queer
artist. And so, Harry Styles is wearing
this T-shirt on
well, wearing his T-shirt.
Now, let's look at the next one. I love
to fellate George Harrison. Do you guys
know what who George Harrison is? From
the Beatles, right? The Beatles. Do you
guys know what fellate means? Uh, this
sounds like fellatio. I looked it up. It
was either to masturbate or to make him
oral. Yeah, fellatio. Oh, wow. Yeah.
Wow, dude. So, interesting. The internet
picks it up because it's Harry Styles,
and people start copying his T-shirt,
literally calling it Harry Styles I love
to fellate George Harrison shirt, and
sell it on eBay. That's how big this guy
is. Right? Like if he does one thing,
everybody copies and follows. So, you
cannot tell me that this guy does not
have an influence on this society.
This is Sodom and Gomorrah. Yeah.
Absolutely, on a T-shirt.
Yeah.
So, he was also on a Vogue magazine
wearing a dress. He really appreciates
cross-dressing.
What's his name? Anytime you're putting
barriers up in your life, you're
limiting yourself. That That is That is
the devil
right there.
in the bottom it makes your makes his
own rules.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The Listen, this isn't
This is so crazy. You could sit here and
you could look at Hollywood over and
over and over again. And it's like I
don't understand how you can't start to
There's no reason for them to fight
against it this bad if there's not
something to the 10 Commandments. And
And you know what I found interesting is
that
what religion are they attacking? Are
they ever attacking Buddhism?
Or are they attacking Islam?
No. I mean, okay, so here and there
maybe in like The Simpsons they'll
attack one of those things. But
ideas. But the major attack is always on
Christian principles. Always.
says when you're when you're putting up
barriers, what barriers? There's There's
no barriers on me because the
Commandments are written on our heart.
That's the barriers. We know what's
right and wrong. And so he's saying if
you
give in to that Holy Spirit prompting,
your conscience telling you this is
right and wrong, then you're you're
putting barriers on yourself. And And
just think about this from from a
pedophile standpoint, okay? So, are you
telling me that if a 5-year-old is now
being abused by an older person like
that that you don't need to put a
barrier around that 5-year-old? Yeah,
you're limiting yourself, bro. No
barriers on age. You're limiting that
person that's going to abuse that
5-year-old. And what what account do we
have? What 5-year-old has been abused in
life and have ever come out of that in a
better situation? Never. Every single
time we have so much data on psychology
to know that if we abuse children, they
have an absolutely awful life. There has
to be boundaries in your life.
But if there's no boundaries when you
drive the car. Yeah.
These guys like going down the road. Do
they like everybody staying on the same
side of the road, right? Do you like
people actually going the speed limit or
stopping at the stop sign? Because I
mean, if you have this mentality right
here, why don't we just chuck every
single thing out because we're limiting
yourself. I can get to work half the
time. Yeah. Right. Yeah, good point. But
the only reason that they're fighting
against Christianity is it's the only
religion standing for something. All the
other ones are all roads of narcissism
that line up together towards the New
World Ecumenism. Yep. thing. So.
Yeah, they're pushing the boundaries to
basically show you crazy. And the wheels
are going to come off the train at some
point, and then they're going to go, "We
don't want this anymore. Whatever you
give us, we'll take it. We just don't
want this." And that's when the devil
goes, "I got a religion for you."
Speaking of the train, do you guys
remember that story of there's a train
and like Satan is driving driving the
train, and the whole
world is on it. Yeah. And they're going
for climax.
Speeding to perdition. But Right. But
like they're partying, man. Mhm. They
are on the wide road to destruction.
Yep. Right. And And narrow is the way
that leads to life, but it's
There's few who find it because it's a
hard road.
Yeah.
And the reality of this too is is I
spent a little bit of time in Hollywood.
So, when you actually And I've I've hung
out with
not not quite this level of celebrity,
but but you know, maybe the under the
A-list, maybe B-list types people. You
just certainly know their name. They're
not happy. Right. Right. A lot of these
are celebrities I met. They're not
happy. That's the reason why they do the
most drugs. That's why the reason they
can't stay married together. And I mean,
if you live in this like free-for-all
debaucherous lifestyle that these guys
are all trying to push onto society,
it's not happiness.
No, it's not.
So, People magazine actually wrote about
this cover,
and it says, "Styles, who became the
first man to land a solo cover of Vogue
when he graced the December 2020 issue
in a lace-trimmed dress and tuxedo
jacket, previously told the publication
that he doesn't like limiting himself
when it comes to the outfits he chooses
to wear. He says, 'Clothes are there to
have fun with and experiment with and
play with. What's really exciting is
that all of these lines are just kind of
crumbling away,' he told the outlet.
'When you take away there's clothes for
men and there's clothes for women, once
you remove any barriers, obviously you
open up the arena in which you can play.
I'll go and shop sometimes, and I just
find myself looking at the women's
clothes thinking they're amazing. It's
like anything. Anytime you're putting up
putting barriers up in your own life,
you're just limiting yourself,' Styles
added. 'There's so much joy to be had in
playing with clothes. I've never really
thought too much about what it means. It
just becomes this extended part of
creating something.' Now,
look at this one. People magazine. Oh my
goodness. Harry Styles dresses as
Dorothy from The Wizard of Oz during
Halloween themed concert in New York
City. Those red shoes and the outfit and
everything I haven't looked too deeply
into this, but that has Wiccan or occult
meanings behind it.
are like a pedophilia thing.
Yeah, really?
Yeah, it's the blood of the children.
It's a sacrificial
thing.
so this outfit for him to choose that
was so meaningful. Yeah. Wow.
Interesting.
interesting. So, do you guys know what
it means specifically that he is dressed
as Dorothy?
Tell us.
he's in The Wizard of Oz. Look at the
next slide.
It means friend Friend of Dorothy means
a gay man.
Oh, wow.
Because in The Wizard of Oz, Dorothy was
very open and very receptive of a lot of
people. And so that's why this is like
urban slang that if you are a friend of
Dorothy, it actually means you're a gay
man.
Wow.
Wow. It's like a code word, like I'm a
friend of Dorothy.
Yep.
I mean just the idea of like oh, you
know, clothes are are are there to
express yourself and have fun and
everything, right? The Bible talks a lot
about nakedness that they may not see
your shame.
You know, don't be covered. I mean look
at what the Laodicean
you know, they are blind, poor, naked,
miserable, all those things, right? And
and when man tried to cover themselves
in the first place, right? They tried to
do it with figs. And we tried to do it
in our own accord. And and that that
symbol of clothing is really like you
know, so deep and rich in the Bible of
like this is Christ and this is his
righteousness. And we have filthy rags
and all these people. And these guys are
just mixing that whole idea up and just
tossing everything into a a cup.
And the Bible specifically says you
shall not as a male wear the clothes of
a female. And a female shall not wear
the clothes of a male.
It's confusion. Yeah. I want I want to
read something out 2 Thessalonians
chapter 2 verses 8 through 10 because
this is
like we're talking about this. People
have influence. These are idols. They're
on stage. Millions of people Yeah,
millions of people look to them. I want
to be like them. I used to be one of
these people. I used to dress just like
Marilyn Manson. I want to be just like
him. So, whatever they promote, that's
what the new mindset is. The pop
culture, the popular idea of humanity.
And the Bible is talking about this 2
Thessalonians chapter 2 verses 8 through
10. It says And then the lawless one
will be revealed whom the Lord Jesus
will overthrow with the breath of his
mouth and destroy by the splendor of his
coming. The coming of the lawless one
will be in accordance with the work of
Satan displaying in all kinds of
counterfeit miracles, signs, and
wonders. And in every sort of evil that
deceives those who are perishing, they
perish because they refused to love the
truth and to be saved. Mhm. And and it
says for this reason God sends them a a
powerful delusion so that they will
believe the lie. This is talking about
Satan working in a way that deceives the
whole world into thinking that
lawlessness is cool and hip and trendy.
And
and that they're all going to the people
that it's deceiving are those who are
perishing. Christians like us, we are
like we see it for what it is. We're
like what in the world is happening? And
the rest of the world is like no, this
is this is like life now, you know, this
is normal.
Yeah. Right.
We are living in prophecy. Like this is
this is talking about when Jesus returns
our world's going to be like this. Yeah.
I want to add to that in 1 Corinthians
6:9 it says it actually talks about the
cross-dressing not necessarily
directly, but it talks about the
effeminate Mhm, yeah.
person.
It says know ye not that the unrighteous
shall not inherit the kingdom of God. Be
not deceived, neither fornicators, nor
idolaters, nor adulterers, nor the
effeminate, nor abusers of themselves
with mankind, and so on will inherit the
kingdom of God. That's literally
everything that these people are
promoting. Yeah. But we are pointing
this out because there is a really big
push in the media for this specifically.
And I think that it's because marriage
between a man and a woman reflects the
relationship with God, right?
Mhm. Yeah, it I know what you're you're
thinking about
love love your spouse as yeah.
Love your spouse as Christ loves the
church.
Yeah, he's given himself for it.
Exactly. So, the Bible's clear about
that that this is an image of God. And I
really think that by breaking down that
marriage, they they can do that by
pushing homosexuality, pushing
pedophilia, pushing all these different
things
um so that the image of God gets broken
down,
right? Mhm. That's what it is. Satan
hates God so much that he wants to
pervert everything that God created.
Yeah.
So,
Harry Styles people are suspicious I
don't know if I should say suspicious,
but they they think that he is gay even
though he's never openly come out of it.
Really?
I want to go down on the dude from the
Beatles.
climate change. I wear dresses.
So,
he also played a gay man in a movie.
It's just acting, guys.
And GMA went to talk to him about it.
Styles opening up about his upcoming
role in the film My Policeman. You can
sense the waves.
You know how strong they are.
The film out in October is set in the UK
in the 1950s when it was still illegal
to be in a same-sex relationship. Styles
telling Rolling Stone, it's obviously
pretty unfathomable now to think oh, you
couldn't be gay. That was illegal. I
think everyone including myself has your
own journey with figuring out sexuality
and getting more comfortable with it.
He says it's pretty unfathomable that
back in the day you couldn't be gay. So,
it's obvious that he's trying to push
this idea this this agenda to
promote homosexuality. And again, I do
believe that this is something that
breaks down the image of God and that
this is a purposeful thing. He's saying
that we're all like trying to figure out
our sexuality and getting more
comfortable with it.
Sin is like that. The first time you do
it, it's like oh no, does is anybody
watching? Like it's taboo, your heart's
racing. Next time it's a little easier.
Next time it's a little easier. And
until the next time you're doing it
openly in front of everybody. You don't
even care anymore. You're smoking the
cigarette right and blowing it in
people's face. That's what he's saying
like
the the act of homosexuality is
uncomfortable for a reason. God didn't
create it that way. But you do it over
and over and over and it becomes
normalized.
your brain. It literally does. Jonah
preached that message to a wicked world
and converted the whole city. Right. I
mean he didn't even want to do it cuz
they were so wicked. He's like I don't
even want to talk to them. But when he
shared that message, boom, they were
converted. And that's what Satan's doing
through the mainstream. So,
um when he was on the carpet the red
carpet for the premiere of My Policeman,
he was wearing a green flower which
people believe is a reference to Oscar
Wilde in 1892 who asked friends to wear
a green carnation to the opening of his
show. It became a part of gay signaling
and would appear in Wilde's poetry.
Oscar Wilde was gay?
Apparently, I guess so. Is that who the
movie's about? I don't know. No. Oh.
Okay. Now, last little bit about Harry
Styles. He participated in a Gucci
commercial
for a I guess like a new clothing
what do you call it?
Set? Clothing line. Clothing line?
Yeah, you know.
And there was a lot of outrage about it
because they believed it promoted
pedophilia. Oh my goodness. In photos
posted on Instagram, you'll see Harry
Styles is holding and standing in front
of what appears to be a child-size
mattress while modeling a shirt with an
angry-looking pink teddy bear on it. I
actually looked up the artist's
statement for this campaign. It's called
Haha and it's about Harry Styles'
relationship with this designer. And at
some point they write starting with
those small oddities that come together
in childlike visions. It turns into a
dream wardrobe reflecting two creative
spirits behind the collection. I don't
know why any children is being mentioned
in a campaign about two
men that have a friendship. And then
there's so much more to this because
this childlike-sized
mattress just doesn't really make sense.
One photo shows Harry standing in front
of the mattress leaning against the
wall. In others, he's seen caressing and
carrying it. In others and in
accompanying video, he's seen dressing
and undressing. So, he's modeling
clothes with this child's mattress and
like taking off his clothes and putting
it onto the mattress as such.
Oh, dude.
Pretty disturbing.
Mhm. So, this is like the Balenciaga
stuff. Exactly. And I don't want to make
a statement like oh, Harry Styles is a
pedophile. We don't have enough evidence
for that. I don't want to make that
conclusion. I'm but I'm pointing out
like this is disturbing. People were
very disturbed by it, not just
Christians.
I mean the guy who the YouTuber who
pointed this out is is a gay man, you
know? So, I'm saying like it's not the
Christian community that's having
outrage. It is everybody's having
outrage about it.
out a statement that says boundaries are
only limiting you, where does the
where's the boundary on that statement?
Yeah, that's a good question. Because if
No, if you say well, well not in that
not in the sexual not in age, well man,
now you're putting boundaries on me,
bro. I thought you said no boundaries.
Boundaries are are limiting myself. If
you say the age has boundaries, then
you're limiting me now.
The irony of this is like I'm sure these
celebrities live in houses with
boundaries around them. Why? Cuz we
don't want a lot of people coming into
our house taking whatever we want,
right? So, we like boundaries in certain
applications.
Mhm. You guys ready for Ariana Grande?
Mhm. Oh my. Let's dive in.
Teen idol number four. Interesting
picture here on the front. This is
actually from her music video where she
sings
uh God is a woman. There's a lot of
symbology. There's the hand sign,
there's the triangle, but even faded
back here is like these uh It's the sun
wheel again.
Yeah. Yeah, these are these are various
These are cult symbols, yeah. And she's
pointing to the first chakra, which is
the interesting
vaginal area.
Yeah, making a sign. Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, so she has a music video out in uh
God is a woman. Now, look at this
segment here and then we'll discuss
after uh what she's actually saying.
And I will strike down upon thee with
great vengeance and furious anger those
who attempt to poison and destroy my
sisters.
And you will know my name is the Lord
when I lay my vengeance upon you.
So so it's a
Yeah, it's a gavel, a judgement gavel,
and she's obviously making a a statement
in a courthouse that
It's like a heavenly courthouse.
she's throw- she's also looking up.
She's black. Mhm. So she's dark
With horns. She's got horns. Yeah, yeah,
or
just breaks the glass with the devil. Or
even if they're animal ears, right? God
set up classes that that man was to be
the that that the top, right? Yeah, and
it's like now all of a sudden it's like
man is like going less than and then
telling God like, you know, forget you.
Yeah.
Do you guys recognize this line? Do you
guys know where it's from?
No. It's interesting. I was editing and
all of a sudden it popped in my head. I
need to
throw this in Google just to see where
it's from. One more thing before you
move on. Did you know that the Bible
tells you that if you change any words
of the Bible Oh, yeah. Of course.
Okay, so this is going to be
interesting.
This is going to be interesting. Pulp
Fiction? Yes. And it and and they
actually blended Bible verses together.
They This wasn't even the real Bible
verse. They made it say what they wanted
to say. And here's the danger of reading
the Bible out of context like this. And
then people aren't reading the Bible, so
they think that this is straight. Yeah.
So she quotes Pulp Fiction.
Uh and so it says here this is from
Genius
uh Jules ritually recites what he
describes as a biblical passage, Ezekiel
25:17,
before he executes someone.
Interestingly, this passage uh is
different from the verse written in the
Bible. And this is from uh yeah,
Ezekiel.
So in Pulp Fiction, I I watched a clip,
this guy here uh his name is Jules. He's
like saying all these things that she
just said, literally those words, which
by the way she also included as you
heard, I am the Lord, right? So she's
claiming to be God.
And
uh
and so and then he goes pa pa pa pow and
the person is dead. She
And she's looking up to heaven saying
that to him like, I'm going to kill you.
So she quotes that saying, I am the
Lord, don't come after me and my
sisters, quoting m-
scripture that has been misconstrued and
then throws his judgement gavel in into
the sky breaking the glass saying like,
you can't get to me. Doesn't Lord just
really mean master? Yeah. Like I am the
master.
So this is the end of a God is a woman.
Check this out.
So I
I really am questioning these people's
logic here because
you needed a man to come into the
existence. So if you have this world
view where it's like only women
Feminism. feminism, whatever like this,
you wouldn't exist.
Yeah.
But besides that, she sings God is a
woman and you know everybody knows this
picture, this painting where God points
at Adam. Well, I Well, it's a God in the
music God's fingers. She's God in that.
It's not in the music video, but when
she performed it live, she was Jesus at
the last supper and all the women were
around her and stuff. So she's blatantly
Okay, God is generic term, but we know
this is biblical. We know the last
supper is biblical. We know that scene
is biblical. So she's attacking the
biblical God. And what a crazy thing
because, you know, that experience of
the cross was the pinnacle point of the
great controversy in the war between
Christ and Satan, right? Yeah. And that
last supper, I mean, there's so many
rich things that happened there. They
turned it into a dance show with like
debaucherous dancing with nothing
wearing. I mean, you probably can't even
watch the video and and and and be okay
with that. You know, it's like it's
awful awful and what a mockery to God.
Mhm. So speaking of the crucifixion
Do you guys notice what I'm noticing?
So I was looking at the left one. Um
it could be
that she's wearing like a Roman outfit
and it looks a little bit like Caesar's
thing. At the same time it looks like a
crown of thorns as well. And also it's
being repeated at the end. So to me it's
like
you know, it it I don't think you can
explain this away if she it has happened
twice where it seems like there's it's
like a
artsy version of a crown of thorns.
Well, in Kabbalism, you again, you
become God. You work your way up the
tree of life, Kabbalist life uh tree,
sorry, Kabbalah tree. And you end up
being your own God.
So in some way she's signaling Yep. that
she's reached that level. Yep. And she
is into Kabbalism. I think so because,
you know, they always wear a red string.
Did you see that? Yep. Leonardo
DiCaprio, red string. And whenever you
see them at award shows or whatever and
they just have a red string, they're
part of the Kabbalah. Yeah, you can
literally look up Right, right.
purchase Kabbalah bracelet and it'll
just be the red string, you can buy it.
But she had a music video, I can't
remember the name of it, but it was all
about the spaceship. Yeah, it had the
Kabbalah tree was the key that she was
using and she had that red string and it
was all about Kabbalah.
No, she's open about it. She she's into
this. Yeah, the alien one. She saw the
tree to the tree of Kabbalah, yeah. Uh
Jewish mysticism. Yeah, yeah. So
speaking of what her her beliefs, what
is her religion like? Here she is with
Miley Cyrus and Lana Del Rey dressed up
as demons and the song is literally
called Don't Call Me Angel. Now, she's
actually known
publicly to get involved with some
darker things. Look at this clip from uh
a show called Scream Queens.
Kappa sisters, someone is screwing with
us. This blood oath will ensure
solidarity among us. We are all related
now.
Let's all touch bloody fingers as I read
this oath.
Hail Odin, wise warrior, one-eyed
wanderer, tell the scenes your missing
eye see.
Wait, Odin who? Where did you find that?
I don't know, the internet. I just
Googled blood oath and this is what came
up.
Norse father
you who chooses the slain on this winter
solstice. What? Solstice? Is that
Wiccan? What does this oath even mean? I
don't know number three, I didn't spend
a lot of time on the internet looking
through different blood oaths. I just
need you all to not say anything about
what happened and I figured a blood oath
was cheaper than buying you all
presents. Look, we're all just freaking
out, okay? Let's just rub our fingers
together and promise to keep quiet.
Fine.
So wait, what is this? Scream Queens.
You know what I mean, like a TV show?
Yeah.
She's in a TV show? I guess so.
Dancing with the devil.
And taking blood oaths and everything.
Aubrey, would you like to explain to us
who Odin is and what was happening in
that scene?
Well, um
in Wiccanism, you choose a god to
to sacrifice your life to Mhm. or
channel and you actually do a chant like
that before doing a blood oath or
ritual.
So they were actually summoning
spirits. So it's real life. Yeah.
I mean, they're doing it real life. Uh
blood oath.
And is there a connection between Odin
and Satan?
Um I'm not completely sure about that,
but any any god that you channel is
channeling a demon or Satan, so. Yeah.
So she's making a sacrifice to Satan and
then he's like, "Let's dance with the
devil. You know, they just do it in such
a way that's like
I just found it on the internet. Come
on, let's do it. And it's just like that
just lets your guard down like, "Oh,
it's
no big deal." They always try to
introduce like taboo things,
controversial things through comedy. Did
you see how she smiled, too, when she
was like, "Do you want to dance with the
devil?" And she's like,
"Maybe." Yeah, it's like
Yeah, that makes the viewer
subconsciously like, "Oh, maybe this is
supposed to be like kind of hot." Or
something, you know.
Here's a little clip Hollywood uh life
where they are discussing that she is
going to cemeteries because she wants to
check out the spirit stuff over there.
Hi Hollywood Lifers, this is Hollybuzz
with Bonnie
and Katrina. Wow, Ariana Grande has got
a real problem with demons. She told
Complex magazine. Apparently, she went
to a haunted cemetery called Stull
Cemetery near Kansas City. And it's
actually supposedly one of the gateways
to hell, supposedly. gateways to hell.
This is what she said happened. "I felt
this sick overwhelming feeling of
negativity over the whole car and we
smelled sulfur, which is the sign of a
demon." Who knew?
She said, "This is scary. Let's leave."
I rolled down the window before we left
and said, "We apologize. We didn't mean
to disrupt your peace." Then I took a
picture and there are three super
distinct faces in the picture. They're
faces of textbook demons.
That is so creepy. It is super creepy.
because she also says that she took the
picture and she tried to send it to her
manager, but it wouldn't download
because it said it was too many
megabytes. In fact, it was 666
megabytes, which is supposedly The mark
of the beast. That's right. And now
Ariana is obviously very passionate
about this demon encounter. She actually
had a whole folder on her phone entitled
demons. But when the interviewer asked
to see it, she said she had actually
deleted it because so many crazy
occurrences were happening. Ariana also
said that she felt like the demons
followed her back home. She had an
encounter where she was sleeping where
she saw this black figure over her bed.
She didn't want to feed the fear. She
thought it was there and wanted to scare
her. So she just called her friend and
she fell asleep on the phone. When she
woke up, the room was demon free. I
remember hearing about the the figure,
the black figure. Yeah.
How do you have encounters like this and
you still play around with it? She's
like, "I know it's a demon. Okay, let's
do a blood oath."
Right? Yeah. These ladies, I can't quite
tell if they are actually like, you
know, almost almost like sarcasm about
it, right?
Oh, it's 666. Yeah, that's the mark of
the beast. The black cat and Right,
right, right. And and and I think the
devil's great at disinformation as well,
right? So he's just throwing everything
in the kitchen sink at you. It's like,
so it's just confusing and then people
will dismiss when they hear things like
mark of the beast, 666. How many people
really care that a black cat walks in
front of them? Nobody. It's a
superstition. So the six Yeah, 666,
whatever. Yeah. Mhm. So pretty dark,
right? Yeah. What I also find pretty
dark is how again she is portraying her
sexuality.
So this is her video Dangerous Woman
dressed up like
I mean any
play play girl, a bunny, anyone?
Again, and I've seen pictures where
people dress up like her for Halloween,
right? Kids are doing this kind of
stuff.
So there's this video here, a music clip
where she is in a club and she This is
called Break Up With Your Girlfriend
where she's constantly singing, "Break
up with your girlfriend." But who is she
eyeballing? Is it the dude?
Or is it the chick? Or is it both? And
the girl is like looking at her like,
"Come here." Licking her lips at her?
What?
And like
this is fully portraying
a threesome. Yeah.
Wow.
Crazy, dude.
And this is, you know, a girl who grew
up on Nickelodeon and your kids were
watching her on Nickelodeon, idolizing
her and now this is where they're
following her, too. Right. Yeah, so here
they are, you know, obviously drinking
and whatnot. It just continues. They're
just partying. Eventually, they'll end
up going to this mansion, to this house
where they're having a party and this is
what happens, right?
He's in the pool
and she is
like talking kiss
kissing the the girlfriend and the guy
are kissing and she's like far off and
he's like, "Break up with your
boyfriend, you know?"
And then she gets pulled in. She hangs
out and kisses the dude and then the
girl's like, "No, I want you, Ariana. We
should kiss."
Man. I mean, it is just ridiculous. I
don't I don't see how how Sodom and
Gomorrah could be much different than
this. Is that Ariana Grande? Yep.
This is an impersonator. Mhm. But they
all believe it's Ariana Grande. I
figured she doesn't look like herself.
shove The parents shove the kids like,
"Go Go take a picture with this girl
that
promotes threesomes, that promotes
selling your soul to Satan, doing blood
oaths and says I am God is a woman and I
am God." And it's like these This is
kids and teenagers that listen to her
music and idolize her.
Another person that started out on
Disney is Sabrina Carpenter.
And uh Church, praying. Absolutely.
She's in church. She is praying, but it
is very blasphemous. So she did a video
called Feather where she talks about
light as a feather because she pushed
aside all the guys that were just like,
"Oh, it's being annoying." And so she
made a music video and actually at the
end she ends up dancing on the platform
or the altar at a Catholic church and
the priest was fired over this because
it was so provocative.
Wait, a real life priest? Because they
allowed her to be in a real church. The
priest allowed it and then the Catholic
church fired her over it.
So let's take a look at this video. It
is pretty insane.
Now here she is dancing and oops.
Oh, no. The guys that were bothering me
got hit by a truck. Oh, well. Here she's
at a gym exercising. All of the dudes
like her and they're starting to fight
over her and knocking each other down
while she's taking pictures of herself.
She's getting blood gushed on her and
she's like, "Oh,
oops. Uh-oh. Well, I guess they're all
dead." And then you see her walk into
the frame tiptoeing and she kind of like
kicks like, "You still alive?
Oh, you're not. Oh, well."
And then the same thing happens. This
guy took a picture of her butt while she
was in the in the elevator and she pulls
his tie in basically just like,
"Bye-bye." And then again, there is
blood coming out of the elevator. She
just killed another dude. And now here
she is in the Catholic church dancing
around provocatively with the pastel
colored caskets, which are obviously
from the dead dudes. She's having just a
good old time
in the Catholic church mocking So so
she's mocking God, but also something
very interesting that's happening here
as well.
It seems like they're not making fun of
this Catholic system. No. They're
mocking They're mocking, yes, but what's
interesting is when you see them make
fun of regular Christianity, they're
missing teeth. They're
whatever, right? They're these They're
these weird like angry Christians and
stuff like this, right? She's doing
She's doing debaucherous stuff inside of
the church here. Even Ariana Grande
doing things that are like I don't know
if
if the artwork of the Is that
Michelangelo that did the Last Supper?
Mhm.
Right? Was he Was he Catholic? Oh, I
don't know about that.
so. Yeah, I don't know. But but But But
do you see what I'm saying by like it's
not necessarily making fun of it. It's
like he's actually using sexualized
imagery Yeah, drawing you to it. Yeah,
exactly. In a in a weird way. They're
not sitting there saying like we don't
want anything to do with the church.
They're literally like doing this in the
church. If you pay attention, anytime
Christianity is portrayed in the media,
it's always a joke. Ned Flanders and all
the stuff on The Simpsons.
But if
quote unquote Christianity or the Bible
is portrayed in a good light, it's
always a Catholic priest. Like if you're
getting married, if Hollywood's getting
married in a church, Catholic priest. If
you need to
cast a demon out, Catholic priest.
Right. But it is. It's the It's the
Christians that are the ignorant
rednecks and all that. Right. Do you
notice another thing very interesting
that you paused on this thing because
there is a cross in the background, but
she ain't looking at the cross. Yeah,
true. She's looking away from it. True.
Very interesting. You know, a lot of
times we we point out like, "Oh, Sodom
and Gomorrah was destroyed because of
homosexuality." There was more to it.
Well, this is actually Noah's Ark.
We point out that it's the the sexual
immorality, but it was also in Genesis
6:11 it says the earth also was corrupt
before God and the earth was filled with
violence. So you see this combination
all the time of sex and violence just
like here. Blood and sexual promiscuity
when you see Cardi B
music video starts out with somebody
getting shot in the head and then she's
walking around naked and they all die at
the end. All these women are naked. Sex
and violence. Mhm.
It's a good It's a good point because
one of the most damaging porn that that
anyone could ever engage in watching is
violent porn. And why would be the
reason for that? What why would that be
even more damaging than anything else?
Because think about this. In this act of
others-focused love, right? For you to
kill someone and take their life and
take pleasure off of it is the most
opposite end of the spectrum than Jesus
giving his life to save his friend,
right? Or to save the world or to save
whatever, right? No greater love than
anybody that gives his life for his
friend.
Yep.
Right? So So that is the opposite end of
the spectrum when you harm somebody and
take pleasure from it.
Combining the wickedest thing and the
most beautiful thing and put them
together. Mhm. Just like you see like
Marilyn Manson with Marilyn Monroe,
Charles Manson. Taking something
beautiful and wicked and put them
together. So Sabrina Carpenter also
talked about her song Feather in the
Rolling Stone
about the whole controversy with this
priest being fired over it. And this is
what it says. The video which dropped on
Halloween
shows Carpenter dancing in a super sexy
black lace dress and veil on the
church's altar while being surrounded by
pastel colored coffins. And then she
says, "We got approval in advance." The
singer told Variety simply, "And Jesus
was a carpenter." Cuz her name is
Sabrina Carpenter. Wow. It's just like a
slam on Christianity. She's like, "Oh,
and Jesus was a carpenter." It's like,
"Wow." Wow. Okay, thanks for that. Now
you guys remember U2 the song Still
Haven't Found What I'm Looking For? Oh
yeah. Yep. So she a while back
song by the way. Oh yeah. Yeah,
absolutely. So a while back she did a
collab with this guy Peter Hollens on
his YouTube channel. This was I think
she was still working for Disney at this
point. Check out the lyrics of this
song.
I have spoke with the tongue of angels.
I have held the hand of a devil. It was
warm in the night. It was cold as a
stone. I believe in the kingdom come.
Then all the colors will bleed into one.
Bleed into one. But yes, I'm still
running.
You broke the bonds and you loose the
chains. Carried the cross of my shame of
oh my shame. You know I believe it, but
I still haven't found what I'm looking
for. That's the song from U2 that
literally says, "You know what? I sort
of believed in Jesus at one point, but
I'm still running.
Even though he did all these things for
me, I still haven't found what I'm
looking for." And this is the song that
she covered.
Which to the Christian experience at the
cross is what we've all been looking
for. The God that loves humanity so much
that that he would be willing to come
down here and take our penalty. He's
taking our penalty so that we could even
have the opportunity to go to heaven,
right? And to sit there and say, "You
showed me all that. You carried the
cross. You took my shame. You did all
that, but you know what? I still haven't
found what I'm actually looking for."
That's straight evil. That's satanic. I
mean that's that is the devil. That is
Satan. Satan was in heaven with God and
and perfection and he said, "You know
what? This isn't what I This isn't for
me. It's evil." Yeah.
Very very sad.
Um and so, you know, speaking of the
paranormal again because it looks like
all these people are into the paranormal
stuff, she's hugely into that as well.
And she did an interview with I Heart
Radio, the show Countdown. Let's take a
look at what she says. Sabrina, I am
obsessed, as you I I think you know,
with the paranormal. Ghosts, UFOs. I've
got a podcast called Paranormalish. I'm
just yeah, off the deep end. What is
this you you like to on tour investigate
or roam around haunted theaters and
whatnot, right?
Yeah, I mean they're so scary.
There There was a few There was a few I
remember Indianapolis I think was the
most haunted one that I've been in.
Do you know much about ghosts in
Indianapolis cuz I probably met a
couple.
Please fill me in. What What did you
encounter? What's the name of this place
if you can recall all that all that
stuff? I don't remember what it was
called. It was some some theater. I'll
find it. I'll send it to you. But
yeah, it was a few years ago and I just
from the second I walked in, you know,
when like I mean I'm one of those people
like I feel energy shifts really
intensely. And so when I walked into the
theater, I could like automatically
sense that it was quite spooky.
And after the show, me and my friends
that were opening for me, we all went
down to like the basement of this
theater and just were exploring and like
it was all the like maybe cliche things
like lights flickering and then like we
lost my friend in the dark and then we
were freaking out cuz we were like, "Oh
my god, my my friend was stolen." Wasn't
stolen, just got lost cuz we were in the
dark. But
I don't know if I've encountered like
the ghost of my dreams yet.
But I'm still searching. What about you?
What's your like best experience? I've
had some doors I've never seen anything
like, "Wow, that's a ghost." But I've
had some doors unexplainably
Oops. slam on me. That's a no for me.
And that was kind of kind of freaky.
Well, if if you see anything on this
next tour, if you stay in some haunted
rooms, please let me know.
Yeah. New Orleans, I'm going to be in
New Orleans and I'll make sure cuz
that's the, you know, pinnacle of
haunted.
So there's a consistent theme happening
with these people. The occult,
spiritualism, and demonic stuff, and
this push for sexuality, and the push
for homosexuality and
God. transgender cross-dressing. You
know what I really wish? Here's an idea
for a reality show if anybody's
listening out this and is this brave,
right? What if somebody went undercover
with these people and got close to this
person and videoed them wherever they
go? I would be super curious. When you
go to New Orleans and you talk about
like, "Oh, I'm looking for this occult.
I'm looking for these haunted places,
right?" In New Orleans, there are actual
real voodoo places where there is
pictures of celebrities on the wall. I
watched this whole very interesting
testimony about this guy who came out of
the music industry and he had talked
about how
when he went to this this place, he was
like, "Wait, I know that artist. Wait, I
know that artist. I know that artist."
all over the wall. And the voodoo priest
was literally like, "You know why those
people are famous? They're all here and
they all do this." Roger Morneau says
the same thing. Again, this former
Satanist who became a Christian says the
same thing. Yep. They sell their soul
because they want the fame. They're all
into this stuff.
actually could see what this person has
gone through or currently is going
through to make it famous, it would make
you absolutely disgusted. You probably
wouldn't listen to her content. I don't
know. I'd hope so. I hope that after
this conversation people make good
choices. Right. So common theme, right?
Occultism
and again sex. Yeah. Look at what she
MTV talked about. Sabrina Carpenter did
not hold back when she told fans exactly
what her scandalous birthday wish was.
What x-rated gift did Sab openly
request? Okay guys, what do you think? I
think she wanted some D.
Wow.
All right, time has come for a Sabrina
Carpenter reveal. The correct answer is
she asked for a hookup. The 24-year-old
non-cisgender artist explicitly made a
request for please while freestyling
during a recent show in New York City.
The icon later confirmed on Twitter that
she was very much not kidding. She was
not kidding. So on stage she was saying
that
She's like, "I want some D." And then
she's like, "I wasn't kidding." She's
like calling out like, "Hey guys, Hello.
want to go meet up?" It's like the the
harlot of Babylon, you know? It's very
very very sad.
Um and and again, like this is what kids
are consuming. They grow up with Disney.
They grow up with her. And then she
changes into this kind of a persona.
And and like you would wonder why your
kids are so rebellious. Yeah. Why your
kids doing sleeping around all of the
sudden? You raised them in a Christian
home. Raised them with Christian values.
Yeah.
How often do does a Disney star turn
into
a famous Christian singer? Justin
Timberlake, Christina Aguilera, Miley
No, I'm saying it doesn't work the other
way. So I mean like we're No.
the other way. So I mean like we're
seeing a pattern. It's always path of
destruction.
Yeah. And Disney, I'm just saying this
for my own perspective based off of what
you're saying and just putting the
pieces together.
It's a way to groom the children.
That's all it is.
So you're kind of grooming your children
along with them
as you watch their content. Think about
that. Absolutely. Yeah, absolutely. So
obviously she's also into the whole
promoting the LGBTQ
thing. This is from Billboard and it
says I think they have to do that. I
think so.
Go go woke or go broke.
So it says Sabrina Carpenter's love
letter to the LGBTQ community.
Um this is also an Instagram post by
her. Happy Pride Month to each and every
one of you beautiful souls that make
this world a better place just by being
you. I love you so much. And lastly, she
was performing her song Skin at the
GLAAD Media Awards and she had videos
and pictures of LGBTQ people playing in
the background.
So
does this affect you neurologically?
I've used this clip so many times. This
is actually a cut out from a video I
made about the Barbie movie. If you look
up the Barb Barbie movie on our channel,
you'll find this clip in there. But
again, We'll put a link right here.
We'll put a link right here.
Uh, again, yes, we there's science that
backs up this idea that you are
literally
Well, you can say brainwashed, right?
You are brainwashed. Your brain is being
trained to copy these individuals.
The name mirror neuron comes from the
fact that they fire both when you do
something and when you watch someone
doing something, even if you like don't
move a muscle. Basically, it's as if
they mirror the neural activity of the
person actually doing the thing. In
other words, by beholding we become
changed. But we all with unveiled face
beholding as in a mirror the glory of
the Lord are being transformed into the
same image from glory to glory just as
by the spirit of the Lord. The Bible was
way ahead of its time.
And God's saying, "Look, if you behold
me like through what? Bible study, his
word, prayer, spending time with the
Lord, you become more like me." This is
why we have such a powerful testimony as
Christians because what we once were we
no longer are. And people see that and
they're like, "Wow, what do you have? I
want that."
And unfortunately,
we as human beings are also naturally
drawn to sin.
And so when you behold sinful nature,
right? You become just like it. The
Bible says it and science backs it up.
So Why does this matter? You know, when
I went through this whole research bit,
I thought of Revelation 20:7-9 which
says, "Now when the thousand years have
expired, Satan will be released from his
prison and will go out to deceive the
nations which are in the four corners of
the earth, Gog and Magog, to gather them
together to battle whose number is as
the sand of the sea. They went up on the
breadth of the earth and surrounded the
camp of the saints and the beloved city
and fire came down from God out of
heaven and devoured them." This is
talking about after the millennium,
right?
These individuals
that have not chosen Jesus are on the
earth. They are as the sand of the sea.
The majority of the people are outside
of the New Jerusalem. God's people are
inside and God deceives them uh sorry,
Satan deceives them again and says,
"Look, we can take the city. Let's do
it. Let's go."
And that's when they are destroyed,
right? It's like the one last hurrah
from Satan to try to destroy God's
people and God and God's like, "Enough."
And so
like
you won't just end up there
by chance. You end up there because
you've been programmed your whole life
to be in Satan's camp.
And I cannot imagine
any loving parent out there
to say, "I couldn't care less. I'm just
going to let my kid end up in Satan's
camp." If you truly love your child, you
want to do everything under the sun
to make sure that your child is on God's
side and is safe within the city in
Jerusalem, right?
I mean, you guys are parents like you
would do everything you possibly can to
raise your kids in the fear of the Lord.
And that's why you don't show your kids
this kind of junk because you're saying,
"I want my kid to love Jesus and it's
free will."
But you want to give them that chance to
get to know Jesus.
Yeah. That's why we try to create things
that are safe for kids cuz we're trying
to combat this stuff. Exactly.
So We want to be caught inside the city
at this moment. Yes. And so
I talked about that earlier.
There is a broad way and there is a
narrow way. Matthew 7:13-14,
"Enter by the narrow gate, for wide is
the gate and broad is the way that leads
to destruction and there are many who go
in by it because narrow is the gate and
difficult is the way which leads to life
and there are few who find it." I don't
think this means
well, God just made it difficult. I
think it what it means is that Satan is
constantly out there but God Jesus says,
"I am the way, the truth and the life."
Right? So choosing Jesus, he gives us
all the opportunity, all the strength to
choose him, all the strength to walk the
narrow road.
But there are temptations you have to
fight.
That's why it says, "Broad is the way
that leads to destruction." It's the
easy way because it's like,
"Do whatever you want. I can I can
Everybody's doing it. There's no There's
no peer pressure. I can do whatever I
want to do and there's no rules."
But that's not the way it leads to life.
It leads to destruction. Like we were
talking about the train with Satan on
the front, that story where people are
all on it and they don't know where
they're headed and they're having a
grand old time.
And this And the train goes right to
destruction because why? Because Satan
is controlling it.
And so we have we have a choice.
We have a choice today.
Right? I know you told me
there's people in your church, parents
that listen to Taylor Swift. The kids
listen to Taylor Swift, right? Or at
your son's school, I think.
There's a lot of Christians standing up
for her. We have a video on Taylor
Swift, by the way. So please go check it
out. It's on our channel. And and and at
last just like do some research. Just
please do some research like you know,
if if you parents have young kids, don't
just let your kid listen to whatever
because music is very powerful. I mean,
you know, it's a it's a sermon for lack
of a better word.
I want to encourage all the parents out
there. I want to look in this camera cuz
I want to talk directly to you as
parents. I want to encourage you.
I want to say
"This day choose you whom you will
serve. For me and my house, we will
choose to serve the Lord."
And I'm encouraging you to do the same.
Like Scotty said, look into this and
decide for yourself. Who are you
serving?
Because we cannot pick both from both
sides and think that we are serving the
Lord.
Read Revelation 2 and 3 about the
Laodicean church.
Right? God doesn't want us to be
lukewarm. He is coming soon.
And right now is the time to stand up
and say, "For me and my house, we will
serve the Lord. Though the heavens may
fall, we're standing with God."
So with that being said
this is a very important message. I'm
glad we all could do it. I'm glad we all
could be here.
And I'm glad you guys could be here,
too, at home.
Thank you for joining us. Thank you for
sticking around with us this long. Thank
you for supporting us.
Um, there's a lot of people that support
our ministry which we are super grateful
for because we cannot do it without you.
And if you would like to join as well,
you can do so on
patreon.com/littlelightstudios
or go to lls.tv/give.
Also, we got awesome Christian t-shirts
for you. Scotty's wearing one right now.
It's part of our clothing line,
Lightwear. You can go to lightwear.shop
to get yours and we got them for kids,
too. If you have some young ones at home
that you would love to gift a cool
Christian t-shirt where you can spread a
positive message. We also got a podcast,
Little Light Studios podcast. Look it up
wherever you listen to your podcasts.
And And, Mikey, what else do we have?
Little Light Kids. So get on YouTube and
type Little Light Kids and click
subscribe cuz we're trying to grow that
channel. We want to put out good,
wholesome, biblical quality
entertainment for your children that
they can actually watch and enjoy and
not be brainwashed by the things of this
world, by all the agendas of of the
world, but good, wholesome things. So
check out Little Light Kids. Yep. Thank
you guys so much. Please please please
like this video and comment and
subscribe. Hit the notification bell
because by you liking and just simply
leaving a comment, you are actually
helping this video get out into the
algorithm. And with that, really, you
are doing the ministry with us because
that means that we can get it out to
more people. So if you were impacted by
this video, hit like, hit subscribe,
comment below, and we'll see you next
time on LD Live.
If you're looking for good, wholesome,
educational content for your children,
subscribe to our new channel Little
Light Kids.